Since I'm a data person and I'm guessing
from the fact that you're taking this class, you are too,
let's take a look at a large data set using that grocery store information at
scale and compare how the data looks first with this big and tall unit table approach.
Then do some quick clean-up and compare the data model size and
other metrics in the VertiPaq analyzer to see how that improves.
We're going to start with 600,000 rows of data and about 34 columns.
I haven't done any transformations to this one just loaded the data set from Excel.
From here, we're going to go ahead and select DAX Studio,
which is one of the external tools so that we can get access to the VertiPaq analyzer and
understand how that data is working in terms of
how we spend our memory and our processing power.
Here we are in DAX Studio.
I'm going to hit "Advanced", "View Metrics".
This is going to give us a wealth of information,
but the key piece that we're going to look at today is column size.
Note that it gives us this handy additional visual cue in
terms of the relative column size to the rest of the data model.
Most of these are pretty small,
some of them are a little bit bigger.
But for now, let's go ahead and eyeball this data sets.
See that were about 6.1 million and
dimensionalize the data model to see how that changes this overall number.
So here we are back in the Power BI section and
you can see we're on the data model pin of Power BI.
We have the customer data now separated out into its own dimension table.
With all of those very interesting columns detailed out connected
to our sales transactions and our product data is separated out as well.
For both dimensions, we've removed duplicates to
ensure that there isn't additional information that repeats,
which also ensures that these different relationships will work correctly.
Let's go to an external tools again and see how this changes our data.
So here we are back at DAX Studio,
and as you can see, the column size overall has reduced.
Recall earlier was about 6.1 million and now we're closer to about 5.5 million.
We can still expand these out and see what additional data
we can glean from this and one thing that pops out right away is that
the customer data dimension has a fair number of
larger individual columns that
don't have information that we're necessarily going to use in our report.
Things like preferred catch phrase or alma mater or a family motto.
So let's go back and reduce some of
these unnecessary columns and see how that changes our overall column size.
Back in Power Query Editor for the customer data dimension,
you can see that I've removed 13 rows with a range
of pieces of information that we know that we're not going to need.
So now that we've reduced the number of columns for this dimension,
Let's see how that changes our data set column size.
Here you can see that we have reduced about a 150k in bytes.
If we look at the customer data,
it really is showing a more useful set of information than say spirit animal,
or alma mater would provide.
But there's still one column
that's been sitting here this whole time eating up all this column data.
Let's check to see whether this is actually useful
for us and see if we can make this a bit smaller.
Back on the Power Query Editor for sales transactions,
we can see that the ID column seems to just
be an index column and it's not really adding any value.
So let's go ahead and remove that and let's see what that does for our model.
Based on the VertiPaq analyzer metrics,
there has been a huge drop by a predictable
four million because there were
about four million bytes being eaten up by just that one column.
But it's still exciting nonetheless.
If we take a look at this,
we can see data that is really earning its bytes.
You've got customer ID for the most part,
taking up the higher column size items,
there are pieces that are a little bit larger like price each,
but we know that we need them.
We know from this that our data model is
at a more optimal size certainly than it was before.
There's one more thing that we can take a look at,
which is the overall file size.
We talked about earlier that beyond column size,
file size provides a general understanding of what the overall size of not only the file,
but also the model is.
If we take a look right here on my folder of
these individual steps for this unit table demo,
you can see we went for about 8,000 down to 7.7,
7.6, and then all the way down to one.
The jump here between the 1,000 to 7.6 was all that single fact column.
Look at the difference that makes as opposed to 13 dimension columns being reduced,
which was between 7,657 kilobytes and 7,633.
So lesson learned here,
definitely create your model,
but keep an eye out for unnecessary fact columns,
especially they are very expensive,
and can really improve your data model anytime you remove them.